carrusel de las artes
maría carolina piña
sí
[Música]
bienvenidos a este número especial y
colorido de carrusel de las artes hoy
vamos a explorar la capital francesa a
través de algunos de sus artistas
urbanos así que quédense con nosotros
que tenemos cita con el parís del
gráfico
[Música]
visitaremos un lugar único de la capital
francesa el spot es una galería a cielo
abierto y espacio de expresión para los
artistas urbanos conoceremos la obra del
muralista jvc quien retrata a iconos de
la cultura popular y se inspira de los
colores de américa latina' iremos a la
famosa pared de over camp un lugar que
cada semana permite a un artista urbano
dar rienda suelta a su creatividad y en
nuestra sección musical conoceremos a
una chica con el don de la palabra y del
ritmo la rapera me dijo locke quien
reivindica su doble cultura franco
peruana
[Música]
el distrito 13 de parís tiene una larga
historia de amor con el graffiti
historia que sigue escribiéndose aquí
donde me encuentro hoy el spots es un
lugar efímero y a cielo abierto dedicado
al arte urbano que ha visto desfilar a
numerosos artistas
el spot de parís es un lugar que atrae
no sólo a conocedores del street art
sino también a simples curiosos y está
siendo presidido por una asociación que
se llama la expo 3 ya tenemos cita con
el responsable del lugar el artista yoko
devenida barea y yo estamos en un lugar
en construcción en el distrito 3 y
nuestro objetivo era crear un espacio
dedicado al arte callejero para un
público que a veces no tiene acceso al
arte aquí se puede ver y conocer estos
artistas que vienen de forma voluntaria
y al mismo tiempo ofrecemos a los
artistas urbanos un espacio donde
expresarse el hostal y ahora quiénes son
los artistas que pueden venir a pintar
aquí a los artistas con los que he
trabajado durante muchos años como mucho
andrew wallace anaconda es un artista
que viene de rusia ella comenzó a pintar
aquí todos ellos pintores muy conocidos
hoy han apoyado este proyecto en este
momento apoyamos a chicos muy jóvenes
como crema germán que hace de este lugar
un espacio altamente artístico
y ahora podrías hablarme de este gran
mural que tenemos aquí al lado me parece
que es una de las obras maestras del
lugar asq este fresco que yo llamo el
lamento norteamericano retoma muchos
motivos y figuras cruciales de la
cultura estadounidense se mezclan la
acción el patrimonio y el juego es el
fruto de una colaboración entre move y
andrew wallace ellos pintaron contra
viento marea y nieve su actitud resume
muy bien el espíritu de apertura que
defendemos en este lugar magnífico que
es el spot tres y tres cortas una última
pregunta sobre el graffiti el street art
en la ciudad al principio era un arte
espontáneo
hoy en día te parece que el street art
tiene su lugar en la ciudad yo creo que
si el arte callejero es la
representación de una generación como
sucedió con los impresionistas y tantos
otros los artistas del graffiti han sido
criticados o marginados pero en
definitiva es un espacio más de libre de
expresión y de reivindicación siempre
hay un mensaje y una visión de la
realidad cotidiana de turismo gracias yo
como por habernos recibido en los solos
veces y presentarnos en ese lugar y
ahora vamos al encuentro de otro artista
que vive y trabaja en parís y cuya obra
sigue inspirada por américa latina
[Música]
media modelo más conocido como gps otra
vez en español que soy artista urbano
muralista para ser más exactos aquí mi
especialidad es la pintura el fresco
sobre las paredes lo que llamamos los
murales
siempre me ha interesado el concepto del
icono por ejemplo he visto que en
américa latina' del arte popular está
muy impregnado de religión y la figura
icónica digamos que es recurrente
entonces poco a poco me ha ido pidiendo
retratos porque iba hacia iconos de
personas personajes populares deportivos
de la cultura de la música del arte y
entonces ha venido esa especialización
de el retrato de forma un poco natural
digamos
américa latina está muy presente en mi
obra y esto es una historia bastante
antigua que tenía un padre que era
profesor de francés y nos llevó toda la
familia a vivir en distintos países de
américa latina ha habido uruguay ha
habido también españa hablando de un
país hispanohablante y luego pues por
razones personales también estuve muy
vinculado con colombia con ecuador
también todo esto ha creado un gusto por
esos colores tropicales que para mí son
muy vinculados al equino américa fuera
de esto también la forma de vestir los
los colores de los trajes tradicionales
todo esto es una estética los patterns
también de esos vestidos han creado
también han sido una fuente de
inspiración muy fuerte para mí
estimular que está detrás de mí
es un homenaje a una gran cineasta que
es agnès varda que murió hace dos años
esa señora vivió muchos años aquí en
este barrio en la ruta guías para ser
más preciso y lo que quiso hacer la
alcaldía del 14 hacerle un homenaje un
homenaje picture al y yo te llevo el
gran honor de ser el artista que
cogieron para poder pintar este homenaje
lo que está representado acaba es una
selección de varias escenas de esas
películas parisinas de años gana el arte
urbano también en ese periodo de crisis
que hemos tenido ha dado un
un sentido especial a lo esencial que
tiene que ser la cultura precisamente
cuando los lugares estaban cerrados
nosotros los muralistas hemos podido
seguir dando acceso a la cultura a la
gente y precisamente es poder compartir
esto lo que me encanta
[Música]
los invitamos ahora al noreste de la
capital francesa a descubrir una pared
emblemática desde hace dos décadas el
colectivo lo mío invita a artistas a
crear una obra en una plaza muy
concurrida es un reportaje de melissa
barra con leo bernal
en la calle o vasco pnv las terrazas
parisinas comparten la acera con
performance de arte callejero este muro
del distrito 11 se ha convertido en toda
una institución gracias a la asociación
lo mejor christine ruth la es su
vicepresidenta
[Música]
y pintar el muro de over camp es una
etapa crucial para cualquier artista
urbano nuestra asociación no fue fundada
por dos artistas en 2013 para defender a
los artistas y promover el arte urbano y
hemos recibido a
334 artistas el objetivo es que estos lo
puedan vivir de su arte por eso les
pagamos por su trabajo la alcaldía de
parís nos ayuda no solo alquilando nos a
la pared sino también respaldando no
sólo financieramente alternamos entre
obras de graffiti de realismo de arte
abstractos de estar sido y un poco de
todo
cada dos semanas un artista nuevo viene
a recubrir la pared para curiosos y
aficionados es la oportunidad de ver
firmas famosas del arte trabajar en
directo como es el caso de rea one quien
más bien acostumbra a pintar en
edificios industriales abandonados cada
modo mi obra no tiene nombre ni tampoco
mensajes solo busca provocar una
sensación es un estilo que se inspira en
la caligrafía al inicio era para
impresionar a una chica porque antes
hacía grafitis con flechas y luego se
convirtió pues en mi estilo es bueno que
me hayan invitado a pintar el muro
porque me permite conocer al público no
podemos quedarnos en zonas abandonadas
este marco permite compartir con la
gente y producir una obra completa
una instalación como ésta trae
conocedores del arte urbano pero también
nuevos aficionados como más justo que ya
no se pierde un solo performance en el
muro
no conocía el street arte pero con la
pandemia del cobijo en las exposiciones
los museos y las galerías que estaban
cerradas entonces comencé a interesarme
en lo que veía en la calle cada vez que
salía y en especial en el arte urbano
idu no partí que llegó excitante
[Música]
por allá de nuestra crónica musical y
vamos a recibir hoy en el spot 3 a
natalio olivares hola natalia hola maría
carolina y bueno y nos vamos a presentar
un artista que reivindica una doble
cultura y ella es vil y todo lo que una
artista hecha derecha franco peruana sus
textos y sus ritmos golpean muy fuerte y
suenan así
él aceptó sin odios a llamarle aceptó
necesario su gente
hola
muchas gracias al mar contratarme
mis trabajos abiertos
estamos en un barrio bastante colorido
en el distrito 13 de la capital de parís
se inspira este lugar lleno de arte
urbano de caras etcétera colores sí sí
sí de hecho a mí me gusta bastante el
graffiti este para decirlo todo yo a mí
me contaminó bastante el rap con una
familia de amigos que se llaman azul que
es como para ti escuela que son
grafiteros raperos pero grafiteros antes
que nada así que así que si me gusta el
graffiti son como las plantas regresan
sin autorización
a una sola asamblea
pregunta yo lo que hace falta cortar las
líneas a la misma
garcía luna llena
estar esta noche escuchar toda esta
tradición de mi canción de protesta que
es a mercedes sosa que sea este víctor
jara todos esos cantantes pero también
huelan la música peruana tiene su
riqueza como como el continente entero
no que sea la música que yo ya este
festejo vals pero también lo que va a
ser más guay no andino bueno todo es la
droga también si yo rodríguez esto es
agentes
del cielo
[Música]
pero siente en tus textos en tus discos
están esas reivindicaciones y está
también la reivindicación del barrio
donde creciste un barrio popular de la
periferia de parís en no te amas
precisamente es allí donde te nace la
necesidad de hacer música de vivir la
música si de hecho bojan dio he crecido
ahí es una ciudad donde el rap está bien
presente desde pequeña no ha habido en
ninguna fiesta de barrio ningún
cumpleaños ninguna fiesta en donde el
rap no era presente y no te podría decir
que es casi como mi país con
nacionalidad no porque esté bueno de
hecho estoy un poco lejana también de
toda la historia de la cultura francesa
si estoy integrada como usted estará acá
pero no es completamente una historia
este la geografía de mis padres también
deja así que no entera es el lugar donde
por el momento
sólo quedarme para vivir por el momento
en algún momento tendré que ir a
pasearme pero previamente ahí me siento
en casa
gracias metal olivares y con la música
picante de beat libre lo vamos a
terminar este programa especial que les
presentamos sobre el arte urbano en
parís muchísimas gracias por su sintonía
y hasta la próxima
[Música]